the Joe Rogan experience did you see the
guy that they just arrested for his song
the coronavirus pill that supposedly
kills the current virus he reminds me of
that old bodybuilding guy what's it dan
or whatever that used to sell fake yeah
but if you look at this guy he looks
like he's selling well there was some
preachers that were selling it like Jim
Baker was telling a corona vizor virus
cure they straight-up arrested this guy
though yeah he looks like a meathead
what they say there's nothing but the
the chloroquine there's no studies right
there's no definitive tests but they're
still letting people try it is that
what's going on with that I think so
like the couple that died took the wrong
[ __ ] yeah they took that could poison
yeah you took algae yeah
bacteria killer it's that's for [ __ ]
koi ponds yeah it's poison they took
poison yeah they died from taking points
they misread or misunderstood or so dude
the media today is kind of spooky with
their hatred of Trump is getting in the
way of the accuracy of some people's
reporting of the news and that's a
perfect example by resorting to
clickbait and saying that they heard it
from Trump but he that's not what he
said what he's talking about is a
different kind of chloroquine
there's more than one different kind of
it right right but if they just said
real simply that these people died
please be careful there is more than one
different kind of chloroquine and
chloroquine hasn't been shown
definitively to work yet and it's not
necessarily safe to take if they said
that that would be great but instead
they had to say the president told
people to take it but that's not what he
said what he said is that there's hope
and we're hoping that this could be a
cure or this could be a treatment that's
what he said but that's what everybody's
saying like if you go and read articles
about that when doctors are talking
about potential treatments there's a
bunch of different ones there's IV
vitamin C there's chloroquine there's uh
there's so it's this cork wind which is
like an old-school malaria medication
and then z packs they're talking about
what is that called
for my facin how do you say that you
know but at that antibiotic they're
saying that that may have some effect
but these are main you know that's what
they're saying like bits people who are
scrambling for an answer we're trying to
help people not not sure if this is you
know definitely gonna work or not gonna
work but it shows some promise
that's what Trump talked about like you
can't give them a hard time for talking
about what doctors are talking about
because legitimate people are talking
about that combination of things like
just because you hate Trump
you can't distort this and make it seem
like Trump did something irresponsible
by talking about this hopeful disease
medication and these people took the
wrong version of it and died like that's
a cautionary tale it's not a chance to
[ __ ] on Trump but everything's a chance
to [ __ ] on Trump it's so exhausting it's
just it's it's [ __ ] weird man well
have you seen ratings I don't know he's
silly there's no doubt he does silly
[ __ ] but he's gotten a lot better at
handling confrontational conversations
with reporters you know I was watching
this one yesterday and this reporter was
asking him questions about a few things
but she asked about people dying because
of the economy failing and him talking
about like and is there anyone that
could speak to this she says it's in
she's playing a game right the game as
she knows there's no real data that
shows if they do that this will happen
if the economy crash is the way they
anticipated crashing and all these
people were out of work for extended
period of time X amount of people will
kill themselves but we for sure know
that economic despair is a reason why
some people go into depression
depression is a reason why some people
kill themselves these are all facts that
we all know like maybe you can't pull
that out of your ass when you're
standing in front of a podium and you're
addressing people and they're calling
you out on this and what she was saying
correctly is we can't put money ahead of
people's lives so the correct thing by
most people's account is for at least
some period of time separating everybody
maintaining this this distance and
putting a stop
to the the number of disease you know
viruses or number of people to get
infected but what he's saying is there's
also a factor that we have to consider
that all these people out of work could
lead to suicide it could lead to drug
addiction and he's right and you know
he's right we all know he's right that's
not that's irrefutable when people's
lives fall apart through the unexpected
circumstances some people are hanging on
by a [ __ ] thread and that comes along
and it doesn't man that does happen to
people we all know that to be true just
because you hate Trump you can't pretend
that this isn't gonna be rough for
people or you can't pretend that him
saying that this can cause a loss of
life too
I think the problem might have been he
might have said maybe more life there's
no evidence of that that's true there's
no evidence that it might cause more
loss of life I think also we grew up
always listening when at a stressful
time when the president came on he felt
comforted like you like his tone of
voice how he how he acted we always kind
of felt safer and I think when it comes
to Trump you're just like he does kind
of remind me of like you know like you
know like a New York or New Jersey guy
like go get this you know Cox yeah he's
a New York real estate mogul you know
you have to have a certain amount of
that to thrive in New York City
[Applause]